サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
早速今日の話に入ります
だいたいあの この話をね
月々一回お分けくださいとどうかなと思ったのは
私は仏教ってどういうものかとか
基本的なところを紹介する目的でした
でしたが まあそれなら誰にだって分かりやすい
本当にシンプルなことだけ言えばいいのに
どうも性格が悪いんだから
どんどん難しいことばっかり喋るようになっちゃって
仏教は知ってもらうところは嫌になってしまったっていう結果にまあなっているんです
で 難しいことは嫌っていうのは
まあ人間のまあ怠けの思考ですけど
難しいかどうか関係なく
本当のことを言った方がいいというふうに
現代人として 地球人として
ちょっと覚悟をした方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
とは言っても 今日の話は全然難しくないんです
ただ このスライドを作って言っていると
私はこのタイトルテーマを間違えちゃって
別なタイトルだと思って書いていて
後で気づいちゃって あ
違うんだと そこでタイトルを書き直すんじゃなくて
そこから今日のテーマに合わせたんです
で 思考は人生の道しるべということで
あなたの考えがあなたのあなたを何者かにする
で 至って簡単 あの昔 かなり昔
1940年代か 50年代
そんな間でイギリスで書いたちっちゃな本がありましてね
あれ 日本訳もありますが
もう誰でも自由に印刷できるもんでね
そこでも アースシンカという古い英語でね
あなたはどのように考えるかという
そこはあなたの人生だと
だから自分 我々は考えて
自分の人生を築いていくんだということなんです
だったら  自分好きなように作っちゃえばいいでしょ
人生は で フレーズだけ出しちゃうと言ったって簡単ですよ
まずフレーズを言ってください
私の人生が私が考えて作ったものであると
だから文句を言ってはいけません
あれが悪い これが悪いとかね
あちら不幸 こちら不幸
あちら曲がってない こちら曲がってないとかね
そんなことを言う 何て言いますか
権利はないんです 自分の人生は自分の思考で築いた
作ったものなんです で
その法則 知らないことはとても残念なことで
知った人がすごい幸せなんです
世間のすべての生命の人生が
やっぱりそのその各生命の思考の結果なんです
しかし 知らない なんでこうなっているのかと
皆さま方はついていて
ああ これは思考の結果ですと
人生が私個人の思考で作り上げるものであると
はい それから出てくる問題に対して次に考えていきます
創造主 支配者 管理者 心がすべての生命の創造主
支配者 管理者です 自己
自分 私という場合は誰も気づいてはいないが
皆自分の心を指しているんですね
別に説明いりません で
理解しなくても結構です
それは仏教の考えです
で 反対しても構いません
すべて作っているのは心ですよと
だから創造主と仏教がその言葉を使うならば心なんですね
だから現代風にちょっとなんか変な言葉に言い換えれば
絶対的な神様は誰ですか？と自分の心ですということになるのです
だからとても理解は簡単でありますね
だから神様を信仰するってことは
神様というのはすごい
わからなく わかりにくい
まあよく全然わからない存在なんですね
まあ実際に実感できるできるという人もたまにいるんですけど
大体は神様のことはわからないということにしているんですね
仏教になってくると 神様というのはあなたの心でしょうと
すごいチャラと言っちゃうんですね
では 自分の心というのはそんなに実感しにくいものじゃないんですね
そこで私は自己 自分 私という言葉を使う場合は
本当に花を指してるわけじゃないんです
手を見て これ私ですよというわけじゃないんですね
自分の心臓を見て あ これが私ですって言ってるわけじゃないんですね
私ですよと言った途端
自分の心を知らないうちにさせてるんです
至って簡単です じゃあ次に行きます
簡単好きだから 生命 各生命のに心があるから
神 無数 無限といっても
基本的に皆の心が同じ
同じく働くので 神は唯一でいたっても構わないんですね
それでちょこっとこの
神様信仰をする いろんな諸々の宗教の考えとちょっと組み合わせてみたんです
昔 インドではね お釈迦様が現れる以前
インドでは神って多数であると思っていたんですね
で それでどんどん多数の神様たちのランクがなくなって始まって
これで親分子分ができたり
グループができあがったり
いろんなことを神の世界の政治的な組織が人間考えて作っちゃって
やっぱりこれまずいんだから
絶対的に何か作らなくちゃいけないよ
全て支配している独裁者をね
それでインドの言葉はブラフマということになりまして
それまた壊れて壊れていて
今は神の名前はよくわからない
インドヒンドゥー教の人々も
まあ中東ではまあジェホワ君かアッラー君かですかね
で そこが一応すごい昔はね
多神教からどんどん現れてきたんですね
多神教はじわじわと発展したんじゃなくて
暴力的に潰したんですね
インドの違うところは
もうまず自然が神崇拝する
それから自然が神と思っていて
それから自然も多数ですからね
そこに神 神が多数に現れてきて
そこでグループにグループ化にされちゃって
そこでいろいろ神 神 神々の組織が現れてきて
いろんな仕事のプロがいる
神々がいてね それからまあこんないろいろ各プロがいたっても
互いの管理がないと困りますからということで
一番トップに支配者 管理者という神を考えたんだから
インドの世界では この激しい憎しみ
苦しみ 争いはないんですね
自然にそう流れているんですね
中東の場合は やっぱり一般人が考えていた信仰は間違っている
ダメだ そいつら殺さなくちゃダメだとかね
バアル神は信じるなよとかね
あれやこれやとかなんかものすごい
争いなんですね だからあんまり穏やかじゃない
アッラーにしてもジェホバにしてもね
ヒンドゥー教のバラモン
ブラフマンかブラフマ神はものすごい穏やかでということで
人間考えることだから
こうやって文化的な差がありますね
とにかくどうでもいいんです
私たちには 仏教は宗教じゃないんだから
で もし人が神は無数無限
と言うならば 私たちにも賛成できます
なんで？だって各生命に心があるでしょ
生命といえば無数無限でしょ
心が全て支配するのは事実ですからね
うん いいよ よくわかりますよっていう風に攻撃しないで賛成してあげることはできます
ほんでもう一人が違いますよと
こいつは邪見だ 異教徒だ
殺さなくちゃ 神は一つしかいませんと言ったら
いいよと 仏教の人々に真面目に言えます
その通りよと そこで解説は違う
どんな生命の無数の無限に心があっても
心の法則は全く同じなんで
誰にだって だってものを通して見るとわかりますよ
例えば鉄という元素がありますね
純粋 100%鉄っていうのもなかなかないんだけど
鉄はインドから発掘したっても
中国から出たっても どこから出たっても鉄は鉄です
同一ではないんだからね
同一ではないんだけど
例えば中国で鉄を掘り出すと
北アメリカの鉄のあれ
何て言いますかね ところが泣いちゃうんじゃないんです
私は持っていくなよとかね
それぞれ別々で だから心という働きがあって
どんな生命にもありますから
その心という働きとしてみると
どんな働きも同じですね
だから誰かがね 神は一人しかいませんよと
絶対的な神 いいよ その考えが間違いなしと仏教徒には言えます
しかし 私たちは神っていうのは心ということなんです
私たちは神と言わない
人々は神というものには仏教は心と言うのです
はい これから テーマに入る前に
この難しいことは面倒くさいな
聞きたくないなと思う方々に
まずまとめてすべて先に言います
それを理解してうまく納得いったらお休みになってください
暖かいしね 公園もあるので
で このまずは考える通りに人生が変わっていくんだっていうことがブッダに教えられているポイントですね
だからそれは変わらない
それだったら私たちはそこを考えちゃうと
やっぱり幸福になりたいでしょ
失敗したくないし 悩みたくくないし
自分がやっていることはちゃんとうまくいい結果を出してほしいし
変な病気にかかってね
自然に病気になるのは別にいいんだけど
自然に年取るのは別にいいんだけど
そこで変なことは起きたくないしね
友達とは仲良くしたいし
喧嘩はしたくない 家族もみんな仲良くしたいという気持ちがありますね
これはできます 何のことなく
それ上考えているならば
清らかな心で生きていきたい
徳を積みたい 死後天国に行きたい
だから何かしらわからないんだけど
解脱にでも達したいとかね
大丈夫です できます 思考を変えるんです
それだけ これで思考を変える
この一番わかりやすい方法は
今自分の心の中で汚物が流れているんだと
放射能汚染されている
それから放射能っていうのはものすごい綺麗なものにも入りますから
危険ですけどね これ汚物ですよ
だから心の中で汚物を流せない
かき回せないことにしますと決めてください
それで話は終わりです
だからチェックしてください
自分の思考が清らかか汚物か
例えば妄想するときは汚物
落ち込んでいるときは汚物
人のことを 世間のこと
社会のこと 環境のこと
怒って腹が立っていると汚物
汚い思考なんですね 傲慢でな態度で思考すると汚物ですね
だから ごく普通の日常の生活の中で考える
この心が この思考が汚れているかないか
それだけ だから汚物が流れないならば
その人はものすごい だから汚物
汚染された水が谷に流れたら
その土地までアクセスできない状態になるでしょう
もしきれいな水が流れたら
すごい立派な土地になって
かなりの恵みがその土地から生まれてくる
それだけだから この心の中に汚物が流れない
流れないように流さないように
流しているのは自分だからね
気をつけますということで話は終了です
これは一番簡単シンプルなバージョン
これからはちょこっとこの論理的に
仏教っていうのは理性の知識人の宗教でも教えでもありますからね
ちょっと科学的に心理的に考えてみましょう
祈りの習慣 祈りという現象は古くからあります
スライドに繋げてますよ
もう間で私はちょっと別なバージョンを入れたんだけどね
それは別で 祈りということは古くから習慣で
サンスクリットパーリ語の言語では
希望 願望 期待 祈りを表す動詞のコンジュゲーションまであります
あまり日本語ではなかったような気がしますね
それで英語でもその希望
願望を表すコンジュゲーションがなんか衰退しちゃったんですね
ラテン語 ドイツ語ではあります
で 私たち使っているインド系の言語にもあります
インド系とドイツ系の言語はもともと同じだったよという推測がありますからね
かなり似ているんだからね
そちらにはこの 希望を表す名詞
動詞の変化もありますね
皆さんはなんかピンとこないでしょうね
何々なりますようにとか
何々ようにと言わなくちゃいかんですね
例えば現在形過去形だったらわかるでしょ
食べましたと言ったらもう過去形でわかります
食べますと言ったら現在形で
未来形ははっきりしないんですね
どんな言語でも でもパーリ語
フランス語では未来形は明確にありますね
未来ってよくわからないんだから
実際使う言語では未来形がなんとなく薄れていくんです
だから現在形 現在進行形
過去形 過去進行形 完了形
なれあれとか動詞変化ありますから
その中で期待願望形っていうこともありますね
だからそれぐらいこの祈るという習慣があったんですよ
動詞のコンジュゲーションまでしてあげないと
信仰の習慣では 祈りはメインキャラクターですね
宗教になってくると まあ祈ることは宗教に関係ないで人間やってるんです
これは宗教の世界ではメインキャラクターになってるんですね
今現在自分にない何かがこれからあってほしいと思うと希望すること
思うことを希望することが祈りの定義です
祈りの定義も覚えておいてください
今はないんですね ないものはやっぱりこれからあってほしい
現在形でもない だからあれは祈り形なんですね
今あるものは祈らないんです
神様 どうか私に目 二つの目がくださいとか祈りません
私の目の病気を治してくださいと祈りますね
その時は目が病気なんですね
ないのは目の健康なんですね
それは今ではなくて 次かもうできるだけ早くやってほしいんですね
ですから 祈りの定義はそういうことなんです
将来現れる状況を今企画することですね
この批判的な単語を捨てて考えると
祈りとは将来に 自分に対して現れる状況を今現在企画するんです
祈り それから祈りの種類
1 具体的に他人に祈る
これは日本語で頼むということですね
やってるでしょ 皆様は
自分に必要なものを他人に頼んでやってもらうこと
品じゃないんです 誰でもやってますよ
この祈りは これは皆行っているのです
何でも自分一人でできるものではありませんね
当たり前のことですよ
何でも自分一人でできるわけじゃないんです
いろんなことを人に頼んでやってもらわなくちゃいけないんです
これも祈りのタイプのだからたくさん誰でもやってるんだから
これは１にしたんです
それで頼み方 頼む相手
えっと 代わりにこの漢字が合ってるかどうかわかりません
で 代わりに自分が相手にしてあげること
そういう条件が現れます
頼めばいいやではないんですね
誰に頼むのか どのように頼むのか
私が頼んだことをやってくれたら
私は代わりに何をしてあげるのかどうかね
そこを勉強しておかないとみんな失敗するのはそういうセクションなんですね
頼むことだけは意地が張って
あれくれこれくれとかね
言うんだけど 奥さんが旦那さんに言えば
旦那さんは奥さんに言うわ
そんなことは良くないんです
そちらには道徳あるんです
奥さんが旦那さんに頼む場合は頼み方あるんです
道徳があるんですよ モラルがあるんです
子供が親に頼む場合はモラルがあるんです
頼み方 どんな時頼むのかどうか
それで頼みやってくれたら
自分が何を代わりにやってあげるのかどうかね
これは物の見方を忘れているでしょ
この社会はと言ったって
人間の社会は それを覚えておきましょう
頼むことは当然なことで
一人で生きていられません
では 頼みの いわゆるこの祈りのモラルを守ってください
次に行きます  2番目の種類
観念的に他人に祈る 神などの対象に自分の希望を発表することです
具体的にないんですね
神は目の前に 神って言ったらもう何でもいいんですよ
もう稲荷さんでも誰でもいいんで
別に 具体的じゃないんですね
不動さんでも観音さんでも仏様でも阿弥陀様でも大日如来
誰でもいいんです で たまにこの具体的にやった方がしっかりするんだと思って
この造形作っちゃいますけど
まあ造形作ったんだからといってわからないでしょ
話によると観音様はすごい方なんですけど
観音様の造形見るといろんな男か女かわからないし
時々女の形に作るし もともとは男でしたけどね
千手観音なんか気持ち悪くない？馬頭観音はどうですかね
そういうことで 経験は大したことはないんだけど
で とにかくこの観念で
神様がいるんだというね
神様がいたとしても 神様と対話できないんだから
発表するだけ  第1の場合はもうちゃんとしっかりできているという祈りなんですね
1の具体的な祈りはできない場合行うのです
で 私たちはなんで 2番目の祈りに行くのかというと
1番の祈りは成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうこともありますね
子供が病気になる  ある程度で病気になる
まあ別に救急車呼ばなくてもいいんですね
だけど ずっと病気いろいろ
まあ週一回 二回 三回 病院に連れて行かなくちゃいけない
で 奥さんかお母さんが旦那さんに祈る
第1 車出してくれと 子供を病院に連れて行かなくちゃいけないと
で それでOKですね 旦那さんが車出してあげる
あるいは車出して病院まで行く状況か
旦那さんにも都合が悪いんだったら
じゃあタクシーでも置きましょう
なんとかなんとか そこはもう祈りをやってあげるとあげている
あげますね しかし 旦那さんにお願いしますから
子供の病気治ってください
お願いします できる？できない
だから第 1の祈りできない
それで第2に行くんです
神様 お仏様 何とかしてうちの子を治してくださいと祈るんですね
だから第2の命が祈りが成り立つのは
第1の祈りが不可能な時ですよ
全世界の人間が この場合も祈りの仕方
代わりにやってあげることなどの条件があります
やっぱり祈る場合はモラルが出てくるんですよ
これは第2の祈りの特色は
自分が一方的に発表するだけ
希望を 神様は子供の病気は早く治ってほしいと
聞いたか聞いてないか
それはもうわからない
断られたかわからない
しかし この人間作った 2番目の祈りの場合もモラルが成り立つんですよ
そこでみんな思っているのは
このモラルを守っちゃえば神様が祈り聞いてくれるっていうことなんです
そこでちょっと問題があるんです
しかし 祈る対象は観念的なので
条件などなども勝手に作るんです
私たちは勝手に神を作ったんだから
勝手に条件も作る だからそこはちゃんと通じる話がないかさっぱりわからない
ある そういう祈る場所をね
プレイなんていうか 聖地なんとかありますね
そちらで行って祈願するならば
1週間身を清めなくていけないとかね
2週間も菜食主義であれこれやらなくちゃいけないとかね
いろんなもう条件があるんですね
それ勝手に決まってるんです
ヒンドゥー教ではたくさんの神々がいるんだから
それぞれの神に祈る場合はそれぞれの条件を考えているんですね
キリスト教の場合は 祈る場合はこれこれやらなくちゃいけないという条件が
そちらそちらで勝手に使っている
イスラム教の場合はそれなりの条件がある
だからここでこの得体知らないものに祈るんだから
向こうは受理するかないかもわからない
拒否されたかもわからないし
条件守ってモラル守って祈りましょうと言ったらうまくいくはずでしょうね
でもこの条件モラルっていうのは
また神の対象によって変わりますね
稲荷神社で祈り方法とどこでしたっけ？あの
いつのなんとか神社で祈ることもね
いすじんごうで祈る方はそれぞれ変わっていくんですよ
日本も同じ神社でしたってもね
だから仏教は法則的に物事を考えるんだからね
科学者と同じく ですから
やっぱりこのモラルが共通して一貫していないとちょっと怪しいと
だって物理法則はもう宇宙全体に一貫しているでしょう
祈り１の場合は何を頼むべきかと決まっているのです
祈るものに制限があります
だから 第1の祈りの場合は
無制限に祈ることはできません
旦那さんにあのネックレス買ってくれと祈ることはできます
カバン買ってくださいと
できます しかし 旦那さんに今度祈ってみてください
私は 10年若返ってください
あんたと結婚しているでしょ？私の面倒を見ろ
あんたの義務義務でしょ
というふうに理由もつけて
で 結婚というのは女性の全部全面的な面倒を見る約束だから
だから私は女としてもうちょっと 10
年ぐらい若くいたいです
やってくださいと これはまあやってください
それは私は祈るものに制限がありますね
そういうわけで 人間に祈る場合は制限があります
時々我々は人間だけじゃなくて
動物にも祈るんです 制限があります
犬にいろんなことを言うでしょ
犬もやってくれるでしょ
でも制限がありますね
だから私たちは犬に頼む場合は何を頼むかわかっていますね
いろいろこの動物園とか水族館でね
芸をやっている生き物がいるんですね
それで人間が訓練させて
ちょっと人間を楽しませるためにちょっとしたショーがありますね
これはみんな楽しく見ますけどね
その場合もこの祈り１祈りやってますよ
この飼育係の人がもうはい
飛んでください はい ぐるっと回ってください
輪っかを出してここを飛んでくださいとかね
ボールを出してそれ蹴ってくださいとかね
いろんなことを頼んでるんです
それはちゃんとやってくれる
それで私たちはすごく喜んじゃって
楽しくなっちゃうんです
しかし 制限がありますね
いつでも制限がありますし
頼む方のモラルがありますね
だからそういう動物にね
じゃあみんなにもうさよなら言ってくださいって言ったら
あれをこうやって振ったりするでしょ
可愛いんですね でも私たち
じゃあさよなら手振ってください
振ってくれませんよ そちらにあのモラルが成り立ってないんです
だから飼育の人が言わないと
言わないと言ったっても
ちょっと微妙に見てください
こうやってパタパタやってお芝居は
この飼育の人はこうやって足に手を叩いてるんです
わからないように お客さんに
これ見て本人がこうやってるんです
自分の感情 希望は制御しなくていけない
第１の祈りの場合は 何でもかんでも頼むんじゃないんですね
人に 自分の希望を制御して頼んでくださいね
祈り２の場合は対象 ん？これは間違った対象のことをの入ってないんですね
知らないので何でも祈られるんですね
神に祈る場合はわからないんだから
神のことはね だからこれこれ祈るんだけど
これこれ良くないやってことはわからないんです
だから何でも祈られるんです
神様 うちの子供の病気治してください
隣の人の仕事をクビにしてくださいと
で あの怒り この嫉妬 憎しみの祈りは
あまり日本の社会ではね
そんなにないんだけど
アジアではもう本当に原始人で
よくそうやって この何て言いますか
あれは呪い系の祈りもするんですね
だからバカが乗るんです
でも私が笑っちゃうのは
神はある人を助けたり
この人を殺すってどういうことかと
関係ないでしょうにと思っちゃいます
それから祈りが叶わなくても文句を言うことは不可能です
禁止です 第２の祈りの場合は
神に祈る場合は 祈ったことをやってくれなかったら
なんだあなたはと言わないでしょ
神社潰しますと 壊してトウモロコシを育てますよと
この場所ではないんですね
祈っても祈ってもやってもらえないんだけど
神社を大事に守っているんですね
それから神に対して文句を言うことは禁止です
ひどい状況 状況やと思いますけど
しかし 旦那さんに 仕事帰りに卵を 1パック1箱と
うーんと あれはなんでしたっけ？長ネギ一束買ってきてくださいと言ったら
この人は忘れちゃうでしょ
結構言われますよ 奥さんに
第1の祈りの場合は文句
こういうことはできます
第二の場合はそれもできないと 3
番目の祈りあります 自分自身に祈る
これはよく これもよくあります
で 目的に達するために自分自身を奮い立たせることです
それはまあ 自分自身を奮い立たせるんですね
それは自分に祈ることなんです
自己暗示 自信を持つこと
頑張る 精進する 意欲などのなどはこのカテゴリーです
自信持ちなさいということ
時々私は自信持ってやりますと自分に祈ってるんです
これもごく普通自然で全然変ではないんです
1と2は変じゃないんです
あ 間違えた  1と3は変じゃないんです
2は怪しいんです はい
例えばね  子供が勉強するときはね
受験勉強の時は今日はとにかく寝ないで頑張るぞとかね
自分に祈ってるんです
だから結局自分にそこを入れたら
データがね 寝ないで勉強することはできます
大体この自己暗示かける方法もありますね
大丈夫 大丈夫 これはできます
これはできます これはうまくいきます
とかね 自分に 失敗するわけじゃない
うまくいくなとか 自己暗示かけるとなんとなく
うまくいく場合があります
こういう3番目のにも私は変ではないと思います
次 祈りと仏教 2の得体の知れない対象に祈ることはない
仏教的には 2番目の祈りはないんです
祈りなら具体的に誰かに祈ってくださいと
あるいは自分に しかし
祈りという心理的な働きがあります
それから仏教の立場からこれから説明します
この祈りと言ったのは
私はちょっとふざけてこの言葉を使ったんで
別に専門用語でもないで
ちょっとちょっとふざけただけなんです
これ 人間心でやっているんだから
こちらには心理的な状況は何なのかと
祈りの場合は 祈りってどんな働きなのかと
仏教心理学で理解した方がいいんじゃないんですかね
心は支配者管理者なので
いかなるタイプの祈りであっても
人は結局自分の心に乗ってるんです
それで心がやってるんだから
私たちは自分のうち心に言ってるんです
で 心に言ってると心が答え出します
これはお兄ちゃんに頼みなさいと心が言ってくれるんです
そうすると 例えば子供が何かやってほしい
あ これ欲しいなとかね
で 心に祈っていると 心があのね
お兄ちゃんに頼めと心が指令する
そうするとお兄ちゃんとお兄ちゃん
これこれやってくださいと言うんです
だけど 頼み方が間違ったらお兄ちゃんやってくれませんだけどね
すべては心の働き以外何者でもありません
ですから 奥さんが旦那さんに何か言ったら
旦那さんの心が変わっちゃって
旦那さんの心にある祈りが現れるんです
これはやらなくていけないと
やりなさいと その旦那さんが頼んだことをやってくれる
時々頼んでも なんでやってくれないんですかね
相手の心にその変化が起きてないんです
ということは 自分の祈りの仕方に何か問題あるんです
あるいは祈りの仕方が正しいなのに
向こうの心の働き方にも何か問題があるかもね
心理学的にそういう働きなんです
だから私たちは人に頼む場合は
まあ断れないように頼んだ方がいいんじゃない
うん それは道徳もらって脅しはよくないし
一番いいのは相手がニコニコとやる気を引き起こして喜んでやってくれる場合は最高でしょ
いやいやではなくてね
脅しかけちゃうと いやいやでやってくれます
離婚してやるぞと言っちゃうと
ちょっときつい脅しなんですね
その脅しでやってくれたって
なんかちょっとあんまりかっこよくないんです
だから できることなら
私たちは人に頼む場合は
いわゆる祈る場合は 相手がすごく喜んで楽しく
頼んだことをやってくれる状況があれば一番ありがたいです
とにかくすべて心以外何ものでもなりません
次のポイントに行きましょう
だから今日はそういう祈り方
あれやこれやとかね 正しく頼み方とか
そんなことは今日のテーマではないんです
すごい膨大なことになっちゃうんですね
どうやって人がそのやってやりたいなと気持ちにさせるのかどうかね
それはちょっと はい 次のポイントは叶いますか？なんですね
祈り希望は叶いますか？叶うものも叶わないものも
逆効果になるものもありますね
それは別に説明する必要はない
願いはすべての希望が叶うことです
しかし 私たちの願いはすべての希望が叶ってほしいんですね
希望が失望になりたくはないんです
それはどのようなことか知りたいのです
仏教の心理学から学んでみましょう
はい これでまあちょっと楽に
ちょっと柔らかくなりますけど
まあ一般的に考えれば
私の希望 願いはすべて叶ってほしいんです
当たり前です この希望だけ叶ってほしくないという希望さえもないでしょう
その場合は希望たるものはすべて叶ってほしいものなんです
でも 結果として見ると
叶う場合も叶わない場合も
逆効果になる場合もあります
それはどういうことかと
まず この仏教によくある
これ有名なフレーズですけど
このジャータカの物語の中でね
500 以上 550 いくつかありますから
ジャータカはね これで 483 のジャータカ物語に出てくるフレーズで
アチンチタンピバワティチンチタンピイナッス
意味は思わなかったことが起こる
思うことは逆効果になる
こうなってほしい こうなってほしいと思うんだけど
そこは反対になっちゃうんだと
思ってないのに何か結果が出ている
と これは普通に見えることやと
皆さんも経験があると思いますね
そうなると思っていなかった
こうなると思っていなかった
でも起きている よく思うなかったことばっかりでしょ
人生で起こるのは 結婚するときは離婚になるとは思ってないでしょ
でもそうなる場合もあります
はい それでテーマを変えて次に行きます
心はすべてのものに優先です
幸福は心次第です はいはい
それから心の定義と働きに行きます
認識機能は心でありと伝統的な定義です
生命 生きる命 生きる生命
生き物というのは認識機能があるからです
生命です 生き物ですと我々が言う場合は
その物体に認識機能があるんです
だから生命と言うんです
はい 物質と生命の区別は認識機能があるか否かです
これもよく私は瞑想指導するときでも言うことでね
皆様よく覚えているフレーズだと思います
で マイクロフォンは生き物ですか？と言えば
皆様は生き物ではないと何のことなく言うでしょう
これは物です なぜならば認識機能はないんです
ここで認識というのは高度な思考ではなく
感じるという程度の働きです
認識するといったってすごい高度なことではないんです
ただ感じる だからミミズも認識する
ミミズに高度な思考とかないでしょう
おそらくね わかりませんけどね
感じるだけ それで十分です
それは一応認識したってことなんです
次に心の働き 心という働きによって肉体は管理されます
この肉体を心が管理しているんです
だから 私に証明することはできませんだけど
私の勝手な妄想か主観かわかりませんだけど
私は言うのは 例えば人間として生まれる時は
細胞 2つは1つになる
その時は  2つの遺伝子がいい加減で組み合わせて 1個の
まとまった細胞になる
精子卵子はまとまった細胞ではないんですね
遺伝子半分かけてますね
でしょうかね よくわかりません
とにかく 親の遺伝子全部ぴったしもらうことはないんですね
この差はどのような働きでしょうかと
だって子供 3人がいた 3
人は 3種類ですからね
似てない だからそれは心というエネルギーなんですね
やっぱり管理するんです
それで単細胞で生まれたら
それからはそのプログラムで
上の子がすごい元気で頑丈で
2番目の子は病弱でとかってありえる
上の子は勉強全くできなくて
2番目の子はビシビシと勉強するとかね
才能はバラバラでしょ
一人がものすごい絵を描くのはすごい上手で
一人の子は全くダメ という風に
例えば有名な人気歌手の家にいる
みんな音楽すごいプロでできるってわけじゃないんですね
後からハチャメチャ訓練してできることは別な話で
とにかく肉体 体が心に管理されてます
生きるという行動をガイドするのは認識機能です
それでどのように生きるのかということは
この認識機能がガイドするんです
これ難しいことじゃないんです
簡単な例で言えば何なのかね
例えば何かもう何かパイプとか何かあるとしましょう
まあもう地下なんとか自分が何か用事があって
それを触ってみたら ちくしょ熱い
やけどしたわけじゃない
熱い それで認識ですよ
熱いということは それからもいくらか歩かなくちゃいけないんですね
また二度とあれは触らないでしょ
それは触らない だから体の中でそれは触るなよという指令が入ったんです
あの認識から まあそういうことでしょ
電車に乗ろうと思ったところで
隙間時々ありますからね
そこでなんかこけそうになっちゃったと
これとても危険でしょ
それでもなんとか それから電車に乗るときは足元に気をつける
自動的に 考えてないんです
あ こけないように気をつけなくちゃ
電車とホームの間に足が挟まれないように気をつけなくちゃ
どんな...考えてないでしょ
だからちゃんと体をガイドしているんです
考える 思考する能力はある
生命の場合は特別な働きがあります
そこで犬猫もその程度でガイドされます
すべての動物はその程度は知っています
自分の国では 国が小さい割にたくさんゾウさんたちがいるんだからね
そこで頭イカれた人間があちらこちら道路を作って森を破壊しちゃったんですね
ゾウっていうのは一日五十キロぐらい歩かないと
だから歩く距離が必要なんです
歩くところでドカンと道路を作っちゃうと
ゾウさんたちは道路って分からないんだから
もう自分の道を歩いて
それで大変トラブっちゃったんです
野生のゾウだから そこでみんなやっていることは
ゾウが村に人家に入らないようにとエレクトリックフェンスを作るんですね
電気の それでゾウさんがもし電気に触れたら
電気ショックを受けたら
あちら危険やと行かないというふうに推測している
だから考えてやっているわけじゃないんです
しかし スリランカのゾウは何するのかというと
何か枝なんか持ってきて
あれあれ置いておくんですね
置いて倒しちゃうんです
それで終わり ざまあみろと
一部のゾウさんたちが
たまたま道路に入ってみると
車もスピードで行くんだからずっと見ているんですね
渡らない すると私たちは民族的にゾウは怖がりながらすごい好きなんですね
そろそろとみんな車をスピード下げて
野生のゾウだ とか ものすごくよだれ垂らして見ているんです
それで見ていると 人間っていうのはアホだから
まあ何か食べ物を投げちゃうんですね
それで食べてみたら ゾウさんが結構美味しいものもらえちゃうことで
こっちで待て待っていれば
だから乞食相が出ているんです
これでゾウとすっごい性格悪いと思いますけどね
そこで車に行く人々は連絡がいっちゃって
誰でも美味しい食べ物を何か何か車で持って行ってあげる
持って行って投げる 持って行って投げる
それはそれ 食べて葉っぱ食べていたのに
今度はカボチャ食べたり
バナナ食べたり またお菓子食べたりする
贅沢ですね はい まあそれはそれで
私は言いたいのは この感覚が生き方を管理する
ゾウさんたちの場合も
そこで貰うゾウがもらってもらわなかったりすることで
また学んで道路の真ん中に立っているんです
じゃあできることなら通ってみろと
車はと そうすると何かあげる
あげたらはい どうぞとパス
で 車行けます 一頭のゾウがそういうことをやっているみたいですね
バリケード作っているんです
道路に だから乞食は乞食なんですね
乞食なのに その動物たちはそれなりに感覚から
自分の生き方を変えていくんですね
この考える能力ある場合は
ゾウさんにも考える能力はあります
だから仕方がない 結構動物に考える能力はあります
哺乳類の動物にはね 特に
それは思考によって認識機能が変わることです
ここで思考して認識機能を変えることができます
皆様方は全然面白くもないごっつい
この西洋で人気のある絵画なんか見て感動するでしょ
あれは思考をハチャメチャ思考させて
思考させて いろんなストーリーを読んで
本を読んで で これはモネのなんだらかんだらとか
あ すごい 何がすごいですか？と
よくわからない 日本でもありますね
誰かさんの描いたあの菊の
あれでしたっけね また見たんだけどね
別になんだっていうことで
何千万もかかるんだそうで
これぐらいの で やっぱりその場合は感動する人は正直にね
私は変人だから仕方がないんだけど
あの皆様は感動しますよ
あのグロテスクな女の裸をね
描いて ああ 感動すること気持ち悪いわと思いますけど
まあでもなんで感動するかって
これ何々さんが何々年で書いたものですと
その時はこういう技法を使いまったと
これはこういうことを表現したかったとか
いろんなことを言うんですね
有名なのはピカソの絵なんですね
驚きますからね いっぱいありますからね
そこでこの好き嫌い変えちゃいます
はい そこでちょっとしたこのフローチャートを覚えていきましょう
1 1 の順番循環ですね
認識機能から生きることをガイドして管理する
そこで その生きることから受けた影響によって認識機能が変わるんです
この 1 行と 2 行を見てください
認識機能が生きることをガイドする
生きることは経験で認識機能が変わる
それでまた認識機能が生きることをガイドする
その影響でまた認識機能が変わる
それでまた生きることが変わる
それでまた認識機能が変わるというループが現れます
第1のループ 第2番目のループは
認識機能に思考を入れちゃう
思考を入れちゃうと 認識機能が思考と一緒になって変わるんですね
それで生きることが変わるんです
思考する生命の生き方と思考しない生命の生き方は随分違います
例えば我々人間の生き方と犬にも考える能力があるのに
犬の生き方が違います
ほんのちょびっとしか考える能力がないんです
我々の生き方は何で変わったかというと
思考で認識が変わったからなんです
そこで生きることが変わりますね
生きることが変わると
またその影響を受けて認識機能が変わる
その認識機能が変わっちゃうと
それに合わせて思考も変わっちゃう
それでまた生き方が変わる
昔大体暗算できたのに
今はもう 8 かける 3 って言ったらわからないんですね
え？ちょっと待ってくださいと
でしょ 生き方は変わっているんです
これ 3番目のループは
認識機能から思考が生まれて
思考から認識機能が変わって
また認識機能から思考が変わるという思考のループ
これは妄想のループだと覚えたってもいいんです
それでいわゆる生きることに影響を与えようか
与えるかないか関係なく
もう思考だけのループがあります
人間にはそれ全部あります
というわけで 楽天的になりましょう
自分の好むように思考する
まず それは認識機能に影響を与えて
認識システムが変わる
認識機能は生きることを管理するから好きなように生きられる
でしょ 簡単ですね 超楽観的ですね
だって自分好きなイメージで思考すれば
それで認識機能が変わるんだから
それでそれ通りに生きれるんだから
それはまた思考と認識機能に影響を与えるから
人生は一方的に幸福から幸福へと回転する
それはループだから 立派なことを思考して認識機能が変わって
立派に生きていて それでまた認識機能が変わるんだから
さらに自動的に次の思考は立派ですね
前よりも そうすると 次の生き方は前よりも立派で
そうすると次の認識機能がもっと立派で
それから生まれる思考はもっと立派なもので
もっと立派な人生で まあ何循環というか
なんか良い方へ良い方へ良い方へ行く流れが
スパイラルが現れます
あれは循環ではなくスパイラルですね
幸福の循環がそれで現れるでしょう
しかし ちょっと待ってくださいと
同じ理論を使うと終わらない
悪から悪へ転換する悪循環も現れることが見えるでしょう
楽観主義ではちょっと止まらないんですね
もし変な暗い思考しちゃうと
感覚も変わって生き方も変わってきて
生き方は前よりはガクンと落ちちゃうんですね
そうすると感覚機能は前よりも悪くなっちゃって
思考も前より悪くなっちゃって
その影響で生き方はまたガクンと落ちるというダウンワールスパイラルも現れます
いわゆる楽観的に見れば上に行くスパイラルですね
これ 一歩間違ったらすぐダウンワールスパイラルが現れるんです
ですから 楽観的な見解で落ち着くこともできません
ちょっと楽観主義になってみたかったんだけど
なんか何か不安なんです
仏教の立場から見ると
このような無限の人間は起こりません
仏教から見れば そんなのはありえませんとね
要するに 楽観的主義も悲観主義も成り立たないんです
なぜ勝手なことはできないから
だから 楽観主義になる場合は勝手なことをできたならばなんですね
これできないでしょ 例えばね
私は毎日 10万円 を設けて
それでどんどんどんどんどんどん
すぐ金持ちになって裕福になるそうで
その気持ちが変わります
生き方も変わりますが
実際やってみるとうまくいかないんですね
これ理由を覚えてください
病人に医者が処方した薬が美味しくない匂いがするという理由で
患者が薬の代わりに大好きな酒をたくさん飲んでみる
これ私は無理やりに作ったストーリーですね
ある人が病気になる お医者さんがあんたこのこのこの薬飲んでくださいと推薦処方する
あなたは薬見たらもうまずいね
これはと 匂いもありますと
でも私にとって酒がすごい
匂いも美味しくて 食べる飲むのも美味しくて
じゃあまあいいや 薬の代わりにどんどんガブガブで酒飲んじゃう
それで楽々に病気が治りますか
そこでこの患者さんが病院に行ったのは
病気を治してほしいという希望なんですね
それで楽観主義で好きなことを勝手なことをやる
自分勝手なことをやっちゃうと結果が違うんですね
物事は自分勝手に変わるものではありません
何一つも自分勝手に変わらないんです
私たちの勝手で変わらないんです
物にはそれなりの性質があります
心にもそれなりの性質があります
水を飲みたい人は どんな液体を飲んでもいいわけじゃないんで
液体なら飲んでと ガソリンでもいいんじゃない？とかね
これはダメなんです 水を必要な場合は水という液体が必要です
その機能はガソリンにないんです
液体かもしれませんけれど
液体だから同じだと勘違いしちゃうと
これは非科学的なアプローチなんです
だから楽観主義は成り立たない
一切は因果法則です 例えばガソリンには何ができて何ができないかとあるんです
水には何ができて何ができないのかとあるんです
次 皆の希望は同じということで
もうちょっと早く進まないと
はい それでまた人生論にね
入りましょう 皆苦がいやがる
悩み 苦しみなく幸福に生きたい
励むことは成功したい
意義のある生き方をしたい
充実感を感じていきたいとかね
まあ大雑把で誰だって同じことでしょう
これは関係ないんで どんな生命もそういう希望を持ってます
などなどです そちらはあまり異論はないと思いますね
だいたいみんなの希望はそれぐらいのことで
しかし 現実は違いますね
皆の希望通りに人生は進まない
わずかな成功した経験しかできない
しかし 人は考える 思考する
精密に企画を立てる 失敗したい
不幸になりたいとは夢でも思わない
なぜ思考通りに生きられないでしょうか？と
だから初めは私は言ったでしょう
断言的に思考通りに全ていくんだと
でもちょっと調べると
なんかそうじゃないでしょとわかるはずなんですね
これは説明しているところなんです
現実は幸福になりたい
みんな 成功しながら生きていきたい
誰でも 現実はちょっと違います
全く成功しないわけでもないし
完璧失敗するわけでもないんだけど
まあガタガタ それだけじゃない
私たち人間頑張ってますよ
うまくいくために計画まで立てるんです
考えて ずっと考えてるんです
仕事を成功するためにどうすればいいかな
こうしましょう こうしましょうとか
受験合格するためにどうすればいいかな
こうしましょう こうしましょうと
みんな考えてます 考えてるんだったら
思考通りに行くはずでしょう
なんで思考通りにいかないんですかね
でもブッダに言われたんだからね
思考通りになりますよと
これおかしいんですね
満点で合格するぞと じゃあ満点に合格するためにはどうすればいいかといろいろ考えているんだけど
うまくいったりいかなかったり
私もね 学生の頃ね やっぱり満点にならなくちゃということを思ったんですね
思ってから満点になる場合は
毎日の勉強はしっかりしなくちゃいけないんだ
先生たちは 100点取るために何か要求する場合は
200点あげたっても物足りないぐらいやらなくちゃあかんやと
と自分で計算したんです
そこで毎週出す研究レポートは
他の友達は4ページ程度なんですけど
私はまあ 40 ページ書くんです
すごい苦しかったんだけどね
でも一晩でとにかく書く
ずっと調べて調べて 4
ページで十分なのにも関わらず 40
ページになっちゃうと先生どうやって点数入れるのかと
でも決まりは決まりだからAプラスくらいで終わっちゃいますけど
そこで実際 卒業試験の場合もそれそのようにやるぞと
言ったら やっぱり希望通りにトップで合格したんです
だから それ一回だけ自分思った通りに行ったんだけど
やっぱりそこで企画通りにね
企画はうまくいったってことでしょ
普通の人は満点で合格したいんだけど
今日休みながら みんなで酒飲んで遊ぼうよということになっちゃうんですね
因果法則の理解が必要です
それには因果法則の理解が必要です
はい これから秘密を教えます
人は貪瞋痴の衝動で思考する
思考の衝動に問題があるんです
いわゆる認識機能 貪瞋痴で思考しているんです
そうすると 貪瞋痴が自分に決まった結果出すだけです
例えば液体瓶 2つに液体 2種類あります
見たら全くわかりません
匂い嗅ぐことは禁止します
そこで匂いは嗅げないように
何かね もう匂い遮断するマスクかけて
マッチを持って一つ二つの液体に入れてみる
普通は液体にマッチ入れたらね
消えるでしょ でも一つの瓶にあった瓶にマッチ入れたらパッと消えたのに
右側の瓶にマッチ入れたらドカーンと火が上がったと
それどういうことかと
因果法則なんです 自分勝手にできないんです
マッチが消えた液体は透明だから
おそらく水 あるいは別な何か
これは燃えるガソリンのような何かなんですね
ガソリンだけではなくて
燃えるものは結構ありますからね
というわけで ガソリンには燃える能力はあるんだけど
消す能力はないでしょ
だからガソリン持って火を消すっていうことは
ちょっと叶わない希望なんですね
そんな単純なことを我々は忘れている
心理学の世界で物理学だったら覚えている
むさぼりは貧困の結果を出す力を持っています
仕方がないんです むさぼりは貧困の原因になります
はい この貧困と言ったっても
この言葉に乗らないでください
貧困というのは この生きるためにいろんなものが必要です
楽しく生きるために よりたくさん必要です
食べるもの 着るもの 体を使うもの
椅子 ベッド あれやこれやとか
どこか行きたければ車とかね
寂しくなったら音楽とかね
映画とかね いろんなものが必要ですよ
生きるために 冬でね 皮膚がカサカサ状態になっちゃうとハンドクリームは必要でしょ
そういう風に生きるために物が必要です
寂しい時 友達が必要です
ある程度で物なんですね
まあ生き物ですけど この必要なものがなくなること
エネルギーがむさぼりなんです
これは一般人にわかりやすく貧困の原因だと言ったっても
こんな心配じゃないんです
意味は だから何か食べたっても生きていられるんだけど
ある人はジャガイモを生で食べる羽目になる
例えばホームレスの方がいて
もう動いちゃったところで
食べ物も何も手に入らなくて
どこかからもう畑でジャガイモを 3個ぐらい拾った
拾ったんだけど 結構捨ててありますからね
形違うものは売りませんだからね
何キロでもいいジャガイモでしょ
そこでその人はジャガイモいくらか一袋拾ってきたんだけど
どうやってこれ茹でるんですかね
何もない でもすごくお腹が空いている
それで その人はどこかの水道でよく洗ってそのまま食べる
あまりものお腹が空いているんだから
決して病気になりませんよ
お腹を壊しません 大丈夫です
生きていられます ジャガイモ生で食べても
不味くもないんです 言っておきますけど
まずいのはバタージャガなんです
...どこかで昔覚えてますけど
ジャガイモそうやってちゃんと蒸かして
これはバターで食べると超美味しいと言って無理やり進むんですね
でも私はバターでなくてただ皮を剥いてそのまま食べてる
ちょっと塩をかけて それも嫌と
嫌って言わない はい わかりました
塩をかけたら美味しいですよと言いながら
塩をかけないで バターもかけないで食べたんです
だから生の方がもっと美味しいんです
ただまんまりでやっちゃいます
だけですね  そんな余計な話どうでもいい
時間ないですからね しかし
考えてください 我々俗世間のね
人間から見れば ジャガイモを生で食べるよりは
マクドナルドのフライドポテトの方が美味しいでしょ
あるいはポテトとほぼ似ているぐらい塩が入っているんです
で 油も大量に入っているんですが
だから毒食ってはいけないものなんですけど
やっぱり美味しいんですね
そういうわけで ジャガイモ
じゃあ茹でたジャガイモを食べる
それよりはご飯と焼き魚とね
ホウレンソウと食べることができればもっと美味しいでしょ
もっと気持ちいいでしょ
その差は何なのかと できることならジャガイモを生で食べたくないんです
焼き魚とホウレンソウと
またお新香と またはなんとかなんとかで食べたいんで
ご飯を でもこの人にはそれ手に入らないんですね
だから必要な材料のこうやって割り当てが成り立っちゃうんですね
この世はみんなそうでしょう
みんな同じじゃないです
こちらのこのむさぼりの原因があります
むさぼりがものは自分から離しちゃうエネルギー持ってます
いわゆる何て言いますか
引き離すというか 引き寄せるの反対ですね
あの磁石の同じ極が反発
反発 自分から反発するエネルギーを持っています
それは仕方がないんですよ
ガソリンは燃える それと同じ
次 怒りは破壊する 壊す力を持っている
仕方がありません 自分が必要とするものを破壊するんです
怒りは別なものも破壊してくれますけど
必要とするものを破壊するんです
内にあるものだから 怒りはね
例えば東京ではなく ちょっと田舎どこかで生活していて
それでゴミを拾って燃やす
ゴミを破壊するでしょ
それは怒りじゃないんです
それはまあ このゴミをちゃんとこの燃やす機械に機械でもそれに入れて火をつけて燃やしてもらうね
それならば その地方でゴミを持っていくシステムがないんです
で 怒りがそういう 私たちにいらんものを破壊してくるならばありがたいんだけど
怒りの場合は必要とするものは破壊する
欲は必要とするものは反発していただく
知は物事因縁通りに進むことを妨げる
例えば子供が合格したいだったら勉強しなくちゃ
それで計画を立てて 1
日これぐらい勉強する
今日はこのテキスト 次はこれ
次はこれとか ちゃんとスケジュールを書いて
それは因果法則でね 何時間数学やるのか
何時間物理学やるのか
ちゃんと決めて勉強している
いいんです それでその通りにやるならば合格するはずですけど
この子供の心に血が入ってくるんです
めんどくさいな これは
とかね まあ物理学のあのはやりたくない
嫌なこっちゃだから これ後でやりますか
とかね ということで この因果法則通りではなく
ここはハチャメチャにするんですね
血が割り込んだら皆様に経験あると思いますよ
なんかと思っちゃっていることがハチャメチャになっちゃって
そうすると結果が出ないんですね
あるいは 逆効果になる
あるいは途中でやめる
結構あるでしょ いろんなことを始めて途中でやめる
あれ 血が割り込んだんです
そういう働きがあって
面白いことは いつでも人間に無知が血があるんです
欲と怒りが一緒にいないんだから
一緒にいることはできないんです
だから欲があると欲と知
怒りがあると怒りと無知という組み合わせで働く
最悪の組み合わせなんです
それで思考しても思考しても結果わかるでしょ
貪瞋痴の思考でしょ 結果出るわけじゃないんです
ポイントはいたって簡単です
私たちは欲の働きを理解しましょう
難しい 理解できない場合は普通でも欲張ったらどうなる？と
家の中でも一人の人が何でも自分のものにしようとする
例えば子供 3 人間で 一人があれば私のもの
これは私のものというと
するとみんな何か制限して
これ取るの これ取るな
これ取るなとかいろいろやっちゃいますね
だから欲張りで自由が自由がなくなっちゃって
制限されちゃったんです
それで会社の社長たちがね
あまりにも欲張っちゃってボロ儲けしようとして
1年以内に会社倒産 欲で思考しちゃうと
そういう結果に決まっているんです
はい わずかな成功はどうやってくるのかと
貪瞋痴の思考で成功といえば
破壊活動 ものを奪うこと
他人を強引に抑えて進むこと程度なんです
例えば怒りで凶暴で 力で抑えてこうしなさい
ああしなさいよとかね
言うと 独裁者みたいにね
まあみんなやってくれますよ
それで成功ですかね 例えば独裁政治家たちが十年
十二年政権取ってるでしょ
あれで成功ですかね ガダフィさんやらフセインさんやらね
壊れるんです あるいは欲だったら物は逃げるでしょ
その人に強盗することはできます
強盗したら自分のものでしょ
でも本当にそうですかね
欲だけある人に仕事をして金儲けるんじゃなくて
強盗した方が早いんです
強盗したら金が入るんです
では実際 それは自分の金になって幸せになりますかというと
そうじゃないんですね
やられちゃいます そこでこのテロリストたちが結構成功するでしょ
あれ 怒り憎しみでしょ
怒り憎しみではテロ行為ならできます
我々はそんな結果期待しないはずなんですね
成功するために 幸福になるためには
不貪不瞋不痴で思考したり
行動したりしなくてはいけない
だから貪りの思考は反発するだけだったら
不貪の思考は引き寄せるエネルギーを持っている
...だから頑張らなくても
別に気にしなくても必要なものは揃っていると
自動的に なぜならこちらがそういうエネルギーを持っている
怒りは破壊するんだけど
不信は逆に何て言いますか
プロダクティブなんですね
ものは作って作って成功する世界なんです
ディストラクティブではなく
プロダクティブ 英語の単語を使うならば
プロダクティブって日本語でなんて言えばいいんですかね
生産的 生産的 生産的 発展的
生産的というと 不信はそのエネルギーを持っています
不痴というは計画通りにものを運ぶというか
因果法則に沿ってやる
それから結果を出すまで諦めない
まだ結果出ていないやとかね
例えば数学の問題をやって
途中でやめないで ちゃんと答えが出るまでじっとやって終わる
そういうことで 我々は幸福になりたければ
不貪不瞋不痴で思考して生きていなくちゃあかんです
本当は思考するだけで十分です
あのループから考えると
不貪不瞋不痴の思考さえあれば
他は放っておいてください
オートで送ります だから私は一番最初にお休みになりたい計画だった方がいましたから
あの貪瞋痴の思考が汚物の流れであると
不貪不瞋不痴の思考が清らかなものの流れであると理解すればいいんじゃないんですか
仕事に対して全体的に欲があっても
仕事中は欲を抑えて真面目に仕事をする
その時 良い結果になります
皆様は仕事でいい結果出してるでしょ
全体的に欲があるんですよ
全体的に欲があるんだけど
仕事を実際にやっている時は欲の入る余地がないんです
真面目に仕事をしなくちゃいかんのです
だからなんか幸いで いい仕事をする人々は
仕事中は真剣なんです
欲がないんです 怒りもないんです
無知もないんです ちゃんとやるんです
例えば舞台でね 芸を歌ったりしてね
金儲かってる人々はボロ儲けしたいんだから
芸人になってるんですよ
欲あまりにもありすぎなんですけど
でも実際歌う場合はそうじゃないんです
ハチャメチャ訓練して
振り付けをものすごく苦労して覚えて
舞台に上がった瞬間でもう自我もなく別人ですね
そこで演奏に合わせてものの見事に歌って
そういう演技をやって踊って愛させて終わる
それで我に戻るんです
終わってからは そういうプロがみんなお金払って見る
儲かる だから覚えておいてください
人気者になってぼろ儲けしたい芸能人になりたいと思ってる
それは欲張りすぎ では成功する人いるんじゃないかと
いるんです その人々は仕事中
貪瞋痴ではなかったんです
それだけ 時々芸能人が失敗するんですよ
受けをチェックするんです
受けてるか何かとアウト自我が入っているんです
で これ間違うところは
この大体日本の場合はこのみんなコミュニケーションするでしょ
お客さん 観客も舞台にいる人々もね
だからそのコミュニケーションでみんな同じ気持ち作りましょうということは
自我じゃないんです 受けてるかないかチェックする場合はね
自我なんですね はい これでわかりますね
ポイントは 次に行きます
あの成功の一方の一方の道っていうんですかね
まあワンウェイ 成功の道に入ったら
これワンウェイでずっと行けます
不貪不瞋 不痴の思考です
もし私たちにできることなら
考える場合は不貪不瞋不痴で考える
すごいエネルギーですよ
それが 第一は引き寄せるエネルギーを持っていて
第2番目でこの生産的なエネルギーになっちゃって
不痴だったらしっかりとものことをはかどるという落ち着きがあって
こういうエネルギーを持って思考すると成功するに決まってるでしょ
思考が煩悩で汚れて汚れてない場合は
思考が煩悩で汚れてない場合は必ず良い結果になります
私たちの思考が煩悩で汚れていない
貪瞋痴で汚れていない場合は決まって良い結果なんです
絶対変わらないんです
ガソリンは燃えるような感じで
性質持ってます 心の場合も
これはもしかするとじゃないんです
もしかするとガス ガソリンに火をつけたら燃えるかもと
そんな曖昧中途半端な宗教じゃないんです
ガソリンに火をつけたら燃えるんです
もう決まってるんです
そのように不貪不瞋不痴で思考すると
心が煩悩で汚れていないならば
必ず良い結果なんです
思考はループで回転するものでしかしね
これが仇になるんです
無知なる無知なる過去から貪瞋痴で思考したんです
我々はハチャメチャ慣れてます
貪瞋痴には この癖は簡単に治らないんです
言うのは簡単だけどね
はい 今日から不貪不瞋不痴の思考で生きてみましょうと
やってみると相当難しくなるんです
なぜならば 無知なる過去から貪瞋痴で貪瞋痴で貪瞋痴で生きてきたんです
この癖はすごいんです
どれほどすごいかというと
皆様は貪瞋痴のは理解するんでしょ？不貪不瞋不痴は理解できないんです
誰でもそうなんです このパーリ語で仏教を学ぶ人でも
ローバドーサモホって言ったらよくわかりますけど
アローバードーサモホというと
うーんってなるんです
わからないんです わかるように説明できるお坊さんさえもスリランカにいないんです
私の場合はできますけど
スリランカ人には説法しないことにしているんです
はい そういうことで 我々はこの癖を直す訓練しなくちゃいかんのです
そこで思考を直す訓練に入ります
ジャシーショーシーという思考の世界と 2つありますね
愛欲に関わる思考と愛欲から離れる思考
これは八正道ですからね
これから 八正道とは正しい思考して正しいループを作って
あの楽天的な道を切り開くんです
どんどん幸福になって
究極の幸福に達する この上昇するスパイラル
始めた時 瞬間からは幸せ
それからスパイラルでどんどん上上上幸福になってなって
究極なところに行っちゃう
いったんスパイラルから飛び出すという
だから解脱に達するまでの幸福の道なんです
ここで八正道の中で正思惟という言葉があります
パーリ語でサマーサンカプというんですね
この中で 3つあります
1 愛欲に関わる思考 それは悪い方
良い方は愛欲から離れる思考
だからそれなりに考えてください
別にややこしい修行っていうのはないんですね
だからご自分が愛欲の思考をしているでしょ
そこはこれは愛欲の思考
そこはない思考をしましょうと
2番目 瞋恚に関わる思考
正しいなのは瞋恚から離れる思考
自分が瞋恚で 怒りで 落ち込みで
憎しみの思考 いい これは憎しみの思考ですから
これをやめて憎しみでない思考をしましょうと
例えば A さんのことを思い出しちゃって
もう憎しみが湧いてくる
もう我慢できない それで飼っている猫と遊んでみてください
猫ちゃん可愛いな あんたは
とかね とかいろいろ そうすると
あの憎しみの思考が中断されますね
それ意図的に修行してほしい
悪思考は善思考に入れ替えるプラクティス
それがないとこの癖が治らないんです
講習に行ったことと同じなんです
他に害を与える思考は悪い方で
害を与えない思考は良い方ですね
人間の思考はだいたいお釈迦様がおざっぱにこの3つに分けているんです
この3つは別に別の思考もしてますよ
この訓練の場合はこの3つなんです
講習所で訓練するのはこの3つなんです
それで他は心配しなくてもお釈迦様おっしゃってないんだからね
大丈夫です おっしゃってないわけじゃなくて
精密にたくさん教典がありますけど
あまり膨大だから今日は参考にしないんです
瞑想を実践するときは
かなり精密に思考の管理はあります
一般人はこの他に害を与える思考をよくやっているでしょ
この原理主義の人々 あれよく見るとイスラム原理主義でも何でもないんですね
加害思考ばっかりなんです
コーランで殺せ殺せ殺しまくってと書いてないんだから
コーランなるのは我こそ唯一の神
我を拝め拝めとばっかりなんです
読むともううるさいんですよ
1 ページでも 10回ぐらい
うん 自分が自慢するんですね
アッラーが だから原理主義者だったらその通りで
アッラーを賛嘆して生きていればいいでしょうに
あれはただのね 加害的な思考だけなんです
時々現れますよ インドも時々ね
インドの人々はヒンドゥー教至上主義やと言って
イスラム人をぶん殴ったりする
殺したりする インドの昔からのイスラム人が本当にいい人間なんですよ
すごく落ち着いて 着々と仕事をして
ものを買うことをしないで
なんとか頑張っている
性格も悪くない パキスタンから時々来る連中ですね
このテロ行為とかやっているのは
パキスタンから自由に出入りできますからね
まあだからといってインドで田舎で昔からイスラム教で住んでいる人々はそんなことはしませんしね
でも ヒンドゥー教は至上主義やと思う
勝手に思ってもいいんだけど
そちらに加害思考が入ってくるんです
イスラムヒンドゥー教が至上ですから
イスラム人を殺さなくちゃです
矛盾ですよ ヒンドゥー教が至上最高だったら
イスラム教はもうもうもう気にすること必要ないでしょうに
本当にバカバカですよ
で 坊主たちもいるんですよ
スリランカで仏教と見る
仏教を守らなくちゃと
いい加減にしろと言いたいんです
お前らに守って面白くないんだと
仏教は偉大な教え 誰も守る必要はないんです
だから仏教を守ると思った途端
何が出てくるんですかね
差別と破壊行動 ブッダの教えでも何でもなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 私たちは日常もね
仕事をして ライバル会社に対して加害思考を持ったり
同じ学校で仲間に対して加害的な思考を持ったり
何回もケースあったでしょ
子供が子供を殺したという
ですから 私たちは自分の心に
この加害的な害を与えたいというね
気持ちが生まれると あ
これがとんでもない悪循環
悪のスパイラルであると
これやめて助けてあげる
協力する思考をしましょう
害を与えることの反対はわかりますね
助けてあげる思考 どうすればみんな助かるのかとか
というふうに思考の訓練する
人は正思惟を実践するために
慣れるために精進するべきです
だから正思惟で終わらないんです
それは長い間の癖ですから
訓練でなくそうするのは精進しなくちゃいけない
善を行おう 行おう 行おうと精進しなくちゃいけない
それで蓋ついてきますね
それは正精進というんですね
はい まあそれで方法は終わってアクセス難しい煩悩
邪魔するのは貪瞋痴ですが
簡単にアクセスして取り除くことは不可能です
思考は悪のスパイラルにするのは貪瞋痴でしょう
だったら心一途で貪むさぼりと怒りと無知を取り除くこと
簡単ですね でもアクセス不可能です
貪瞋痴 気づくとすでに感情の虜になっているんです
欲張らないようにするさ
怒らないようにしようって思ってもね
気づくともう虜になっている
感情から思考が現れ 思考が感情を養うというプロセス
プロセスで心は働きます
だから科学的に考えましょう
まず貪瞋痴の感情がある
それから思考が現れる
思考が現れて感情を養う
どんな感情？貪瞋痴を養う
すべて無常だから栄養がないと死ぬんです
貪瞋痴も だからすごいずるいんですよ
永遠に栄養が入るように
供給できるようにシステムができているんです
すべて無常だから 栄養がなければ死ぬんです
何でも 太陽も永遠じゃないんです
うん 水素が減っていくと爆発して死ぬんです
なんで太陽爆発死ぬかというと
太陽はプログラム組んでないんですよ
ずっとどこかから水素のね
水素です 水素をずっと供給しましょうと
なくなる なくなる分を全部入れてあげましょうとかないんです
だから物質の場合は明確に消えることわかります
心の場合はえらいずるいんですよ
エネルギーは入るループ作っているんです
こういうループです 貪瞋痴がある
それで思考する 貪瞋痴の思考
貪瞋痴の思考するとまた貪瞋痴が生まれる
それが貪瞋痴にフィードバックする
だから一生だけ貪瞋痴があるなんです
思考するたびに貪瞋痴が元気になるんです
みんなやっていることはそういうことです
ただ ちらっと見た人のことを
あ 可愛い人だなとだなと
ちょっとちらっと欲が生まれる
それから思考する あの人って可愛いね
どこの辺に住んでいる人でしょうかねとかね
どうやってちょっと話すことができるんでしょうか？とかね
どうやってナンパできるのかとかね
それで考えるたびに欲がどんどん増えたんですよ
実行できる話 考え 実行できるか
それは別です ちらっと見た人が可愛いなと思って欲が生まれたことは
それでその人を好きになることできるかそれはわかりませんだけど
こちらではいっぱい欲が生まれてるはずなんです
思考で この悪循環のループ
お釈迦様が善い循環に使っているんです
意図的に不貪不瞋不痴の思考すると
感情が栄養失調になります
だから貪瞋痴があるでしょ
貪瞋痴が思考させないでしょ
させない 意図的に無理に不貪不瞋不痴の思考する
そうすると栄養失調 それが道です
それしか方法はないんです
貪瞋痴をトントンと取って捨てることはできません
はい 思考の管理  1 思考と妄想を区別する
えーと 何時になったっけ？今日は何の時計も何も持ってない
9時までなんです 9時までなんです
今何時？ 8時45分です
あと15分  あと15分
じゃあ空きなしヴィパッサナーしていきます
皆様に思考管理する方法を教えます
1 思考と妄想を区別しましょう
妄想は感情の波ですが
思考には感情と具体的なデータが必要です
妄想はいくらでもできる
なぜならば あの貪瞋痴が回転するだけです
これはやりたいんです
誰だって そういう風に妄想
できてるんです 心が 思考する場合はいろいろデータが必要です
妄想では必ず不幸に陥る
妄想するともう決まって不幸に陥る
はい  2番目の方法 思考妄想にチェックを入れる
妄想には妄想やこれはやばいとチェックした方がいいんだけど
このチェック入れる場合は
善か悪か 役に立つかないか
幸福を感じるか不幸を感じるかでチェック入れる
例えば妄想するでしょ
妄想するときに自分に聞いてみてください
今私は幸せ？と聞いたら
とんでもない不幸ということがわかるんです
何か大事なことをやっていると幸せ感じるんです
例えば晩御飯の献立を考えるとき
どんなご飯にしようかと
その時そのお母さんが幸せを感じているんです
大事なことだから どんな料理にしようかなとかね
幸せを感じているんです
しかし 妄想していると
うちの旦那にもうちょっと給料があった方がいいのにとかね
この人はもうちょっとあれになればいい
これになればいいとか思っちゃうと妄想でしょ
それで不幸を感じるんです
だから妄想しているとすぐチェック入れてみてください
最後のチェック 幸福か不幸かと
他の思考の場合も これは善思考
悪思考どちら？こんな思考役に立つ
役に立ってない チェック入れとくだけ
それで治りますからね
3番目 置き換える訓練があります
悪思考が現れたら善思考で置き換える訓練
何か歪んだ不幸になる思考で
この思考をやめて こういう思考をしますと置き換える訓練
さらに私は置き換える訓練は説明します
それは心を癒すということで説明します
貪瞋痴の思考で心は萎縮しています
焼かれています たまにでも心を癒しましょう
貪瞋痴で思考せざるを得ない状態ですけど
それで破壊 破壊 破壊して不幸
不幸になるんです だからたまに心を癒しましょう
慈悲喜捨の思考 やってみるんです
皆様知っている慈悲の実践
慈悲の瞑想 その時心が癒されます
貪瞋痴じゃないんです
それが置き換える機能なんです
世間のことで 仕事のことで
家族のことで もう悩んで悩んで
もう嫌で嫌でいても立ってもいられなくなっちゃうと
悪思考でしょ はい 一旦そこを置き換えましょう
慈悲の実践する 頭いっぱいその思考にする
あるいは無常の思考 くだらん妄想をやめて
無常だなあね 全部ね こんなこともね
みるみるうちに変化しているんだとかね
見てみると何でも無常で見えるんですよ
川を見ても こういう光を見てもね
どんどんね 退化していくんですね
私たちに至っても 皆様ももうすごい疲れてるでしょう
無常なんですね 前は元気でしたのに
無常で今はクタクタ疲れている
それでも講演が終わって外に出たら
なんとなくまた無常だから疲れも無常で消えちゃうねとかね
それでこの中にいる時の気持ちは
外に出た途端別な気持ちになる
ああ 気持ちは無常だなあとかね
駅まで歩く時 また気持ち変わって変わって変わっていくでしょ
そういう風に無常の思考をする
それで心が癒されます
それも思考の訓練です
あるいは呼吸数念という呼吸瞑想がありますね
時々 1日時間かけて 1時間30分とか呼吸瞑想をしてみる
あるいは無常随念がありますね
それも瞑想だよ 無常随念
私は不浄随念と書きたかったでしょうと思いますけどね
まあいいんです あるいは仏法僧の 24の徳を唱える
仏教の方々には我々テキストをあげているんだから
仏教でない方々がやる必要はないんだけど
イティピソカワラありますね
あれ唱えるんです まずパーリ語で唱えて
それからもっと綺麗な声で日本語の訳を読んでみて
これを何回繰り返してみると
例えば 15分かかったならば 15
分間清らかな思考です
これで結構功徳になります
思考が変わったんです
だったら人生変わるんです
もう決まりです あるいは読経する
慈経とかね また 教会の方々には独自なんとかテキストは持っているでしょ
あれ 声出して読んでみてください
発音間違ってもいいし
しかし 私が推奨したいのは
必ず日本語の訳も読んでください
節を入れて これは経典は勉強だけじゃなくて
瞑想のためにもあるんです
これ 独自習慣はそうやってできたんです
お経をあげるのは お釈迦様に教えてあげるためじゃないんです
我々の瞑想なんです だから
そういう風に時間を使ってみる
このちょっとポイントが
これには 20 20時間からいくらも時間は取れ取られます
でもすごい最高なんです
1 日中汚い汚れた思考で
もう不幸から不幸へ堕落の道を歩くんじゃなくて
一旦やめてちょっと下がってみるということだから
堕落から その間で心も癒されます
それであの一方的にダウンスパイラルから下方にいってる不幸のスパイラルからちょっと外れることはできます
まあ上のように何かを選んで一定の時間
その思考で生活すると心は癒されます
これ長く説明したのは思考を置き換えるという修行なんです
決まった時間 全概念を念じると心は癒されるだけではなく
感情に負けることも少なくなっていきます
結果は貪瞋痴に負けることがどんどんできなくなります
もう貪瞋痴に栄養をあげていないんだからね
あの間に 癒しの時間は善思考をしているので
それによって良い結果が得られます
ブッダに説かれた真理を理解し
納得することと ヴィパッサナー実践は最良の治療です
それはもう最高の それ以上のものはないんです
だから皆様の心がね 思考を直したければ
ブッダの教えをね あれは真理ですからね
宗教じゃないんです 勉強して
理解して 納得いくまで理解してください
それから人生は好転ばっかしなんです
終わり がない輪廻 まあここら辺でやめてもいいと思いますけど
善思考で貪瞋痴に栄養を与えないことにしても完治はしないんです
この貪瞋痴ってひどいもんですよ
栄養を与えないと仮死状態になっちゃうんです
いわゆる睡眠状態になるだけなんです
あの熊さんと同じく寝る
冬は冬眠する 死んだわけじゃないんで
だから我々は栄養を与えないでいる間はいいんです
いわゆる不貪不瞋痴の思考でいれば
これいつでもできないでしょうに
時々休んじゃう 休んだところで貪瞋痴が戻ってくるんです
善思考で貪瞋痴に栄養を与えないことにしても完治しないんですね
よしよし また生きるために煩悩が必要です
本当は生きるっていうことは煩悩の仕事なんです
ですから 悪 不幸を司っている悪思考が現れるんです
これはもう輪廻でいる限り貪瞋痴があるんです
貪瞋痴がなくなったら解脱なんです
解脱に達しているのはもう聖者です
もう人間じゃないんです
生き物でもないんです
だから生きている間は貪瞋痴です
生きていきたいと思っている間は貪瞋痴なんです
だからもう思考訓練しても現れるんだということを覚えておいてください
そのたび訓練しなくてはならない
これは食べる 呼吸するなどの行為と似ています
お腹が空いて食べて それで終了じゃないんで
また空くんです まだ食べなくちゃ
吸って吐いて酸素を入れました
終わっちゃうではないでしょう
また吸ったり吐いたり
吸ったり吐いたり すべて生きることはそうやって輪廻で成り立っている
終わりがないように 吸ったら吐く
吐いたら吸う ご飯食べたらまた食べなくちゃ
また食べなくちゃとか
それで貪瞋痴をなくして不貪不瞋痴の訓練して幸福になっても
また現れるんだから またやらなくちゃ
またまたやらなくちゃ
切りがないんです 煩悩を根絶することで完了です
だからブッダはあのね
善行為したって意味ないないよと
面倒くさいんだと 善行為すること切りがない
食べることで終わらないでしょ
問題は また食べなくちゃいかんだから
だから貪瞋痴を根絶しましょう
そこで貪瞋痴を取って取り除くのはできれば簡単だけどできないんです
その代わりに不貪不瞋不痴の思考を持って
観察能力を持って智慧を育てるんです
智慧が現れると栄養を与えないだけじゃなくて
睡眠状態でいた貪瞋痴がビシッと弾けちゃうんです
で それで終わり だからヴィパッサナー瞑想を実況中継していると
貪瞋痴は働かないんです
無色透明の完全綺麗な心です
上げます 運びます 下ろします
言っている時はみんないい加減にやっているんだけど
左足を上げます 運びます
下ろします と言っている瞬間で心はものすごい綺麗なんですよ
貪瞋痴がないんです 何もないんです
そうやっていると 物事の有様が見えてきて
自分というものがないと見えてきて
智慧が出てくるんです
それで瞑想中は貪瞋痴が寝ているんです
それで瞑想一旦休んでドーンと寝ちゃう
寝ると あるいは誰かと喋ると貪瞋痴が現れてくる
それで智慧が現れたら
あの貪瞋痴がずっと睡眠状態で睡眠中
睡眠時間長すぎちゃって
さらに弱くなっちゃって弾けちゃう
それで解脱する それから完了
終わり なすべきことは成し終えたという状態になります
はい 次 あの これあの後書きとして入れたかったんですけど
本当は要らないポイントですね
幸福を狙うことも欲ではないでしょうかと
例えば仏教で欲は良くないと言ったら
あんた方は解脱を欲しくて瞑想しているでしょ
あるいは解脱に達したいと
あれも欲ではないかと
たくさん儲けるために施しをするならば
その通りです 例えばむさぼりは良くない
施しはいいことや善行やと
じゃあ施ししたら幸福になるんで
じゃあ私はたくさん儲かりたいんだから施しをするんだと
結構やっています その目的と
仏教のこの国では それはまあ欲です
汚れた手で食べ物を食べるようなものです
その場合は 施しをすることは善行為でしょ
慈悲の瞑想をすることも善行為でしょ
でも慈悲の瞑想をすると
この体の要素が美しくなるんだそうです
私はすごく醜く見えるのは慈悲の瞑想していないから
で 慈悲の瞑想をすると結構要素が美しくするとかありますから
ああ 私は綺麗に見えたいな
みんなに好かれたいなと思って慈悲の瞑想をする
それでも慈悲の瞑想だから善行為です
しかし これ例えると あれ欲ですからね
汚れた手で食べ物を食べるんですね
手がすごく汚れている
あまりいいとは言えないんですね
手を洗った方がいいんですね
でも死ぬわけじゃないんだけどね
死ぬ可能性もある 損するか得するか
認められるか否かなどを気にせず
訓練して善思考だけをできるように力を上げるという目的で頑張ることは正しいです
文章は長いんだけどね
だからとにかく実況中継で頑張ると
結果はどうでもいいやと
そんな感じでやるんです
そうすると欲に汚れないんです
例えば人に何か人を助けたくなった
助けてもらって その人は幸福になるだろう
私を感謝するでしょう
それはどうでもいいんです
助けてあげたら その人はありがとうと一言言わなくてもいいんです
いいことだからやる 終わり
そういうことで善行為をする
瞑想を実践する 慈悲の瞑想をする
慈悲の瞑想 徳がたくさんありますから
やるんじゃなくて いいことだからやる
正しいんだからやるということで
清らかな手でご飯を食べることになるんです
結果は気にする必要はない
なぜならば気にしなくてもいいんです
善人は善果になります
ガソリンは燃やし...燃えてほしいと気にしても気にした意味がないでしょ
燃えますから だからいらんこといらんですよ
だから余計ですよ あんなのは
人は結果を気にする それは余計です
方法は正しいか 諦めず頑張れるかを気にした方が良い
結果 気にすることは余計です
適量の水と米を入れて炊飯器のスイッチを入れたら
入れたならば心配して 3 分ごとに炊飯器の蓋を開けて調べる必要はありません
結果 忘れちゃう  ...米入れて
水を入れて 炊飯器入れて
スイッチ入れた それで放っておいてください
因果法則で結果出ますからね
3分ごとにこれ開けちゃうとまずい結果になるでしょ
石を上に投げたら落ちる
心配して落ちさせない必要はありませんね
落ちなかったら困る じゃあ落とせます
落ちさせます 落ちさせるという言葉じゃなかったんです
あのパソコンの中に なんで余計なことするんですかね
人間が だから この解脱を目指すこともよくではないかという質問に対しての答えです
はい これで終わりですが
思考を正して幸福の道を開きましょう
人生は思考次第です 以上です
どうもありがとうございます
マサオ先生 ありがとうございました
それでは最後に回向の文を皆様でお唱えして終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビートゥアジャンツーサッブルーポーウィナッサトゥマーテーパータンターラーヨースケーディーガーユコーバババウトサッブマンガランラッカンサッブデヴァター
サッブブッダヌバーヴェーナサッブダマーヌバーヴェーナサッブサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダースッティパヴァンテティアビワダナシーリーッスニッチャンマッターパチャイノー
チャッタールーダンマワッダンティアユワンノースカンバラノーアーユラーローゲサンパッティサッブサンパッティミーワチェアトーニッバーナサンパッティ
イミナーテーサミンジュトゥ
サーードゥサーードゥサーードゥ
では あちらの時間ちょうかします